but what I hate is the is the medical  professionals who instead of helping you  with that and how instead of helping you  to accept who you really are and find  joy and fulfillment in it  they're trying to make a quick buck and  they're selling you false promises and  they're telling you this stuff is based  on long-term studies and they're lying  to you because it's not there have never  been any reliable long-term studies on  almost all of this stuff because the  fact is the medical industry only  started doing this at such a large scale  recently so they couldn't have the data  they're pretending that they do they're  lying and that's what I hate  that's that's the immorality  [Applause]